Chào tình dí gây nó nhiều.
Vào tình dành thăm mắt quá rồi.
Nói tình mùa không và khi có chứng gạm,
mà mình chờ chứng gạm nó mình nở ra hành con nhỏ.
Mình thấy, mình tháng hoàn à đẹo rồi.
Nói tình thấy không phải lắng có bắt bắt bắt bắt bắt.
Cả chắc tục có, thì mình nồi không phải tháng.
Mình thô rời mấy con, bây giờ được 2 ta.
Tháng chân có 1 thụ lập 1 mắt kéo.
Gạm, mình mới bắt kìm.
Gạm.
Điều bởi mời, đời đàn lên mình thôi.
Bắc như bò lên đâu, mình bà ta là mình tài khóc nơi nước cạch, tất bà không đề nơi nước.
Nó được rồi.
Cố gồm, có những cái chợi gọi đó là cạo.
Thì có những cái chó, có những cái chó là nó cạo.
Thì có những cái chó là nó có những cái chó là nó có chó là nó cạo.
Đúng rồi, có hòm.
Lâu phải khiến, giữ cái tác gần, giữa nó là tạo cái sinh kế và con ở xung quan.
Cái sản khó mở về là những ngày này khác là thử người lại.